hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots what's what's what what cost
Glenn Beck more money Eric jly or uh
Elijah schaer's handsy ways his monthly
payment to Netanyahu probably is number
one gotta be Numero Uno on that list
it's like it's fine because Glen Beck's
like oh it's fine I give all this money
to Israel I got plenty of money I just
bought the helicopter that killed those
two go kids in the Twilight Zone movie
somebody cost me a lot of money I bought
it directly from Jonathan Landis I don't
think you could I think I don't think
you're allowed to say that could you
imagine if Glen like you see that
helicopter right there Twilight Z Z own
movie it's the one that killed those two
PS check the glove compartment gun that
killed Brandon
Lee he only collects cl's new morbid
collection check check the chamber on
that revolver the last bullet in it's
the next one in the that was in in uh oh
[__] I forgot his name good job V great
job merry Christmas's hand [__] that was
a good joke nailed godamn it you nailed
it you nailed it [__] Alec Baldwin [__]
yeah it's fine hey you like my pants see
that belt kerins thanks for saving me
pessy Kines belt that's the hot tub Dan
Schneider sat in with a [__] man of
bindes why is it filled with
[__] had to have it flown here by
helicopter they had to be
careful Matthew Perry one Matthew
Perry's hot tub seven hot tubs all the
all the hot tubs people have died in an
history his back like 18 hot tubs I love
the fact of glenbeck just starting a
morbid pled Hollywood like that sounds
so [__] hilarious this is the this is
the couch that John Ritter used to trip
over all the time Planet Holly
couldn't hey you see that you see that
that case right there yeah that's uh
Philip Seymour Hoffman's
rig loved it it's right next to Paul
Walker's
Porsche oh [__] see that glass case over
there yeah that's the ghost boy from Two
Men and A little lady [__] Christ
check the closet I have all the belts
that Bob Crane hung himself with God
damn it see that pillow that's uh Heath
Ledger's
vomit all he Ledger hey you see that
that's Greg ger that's Greg Geraldo
sponsor unanswered phone
call I actually have the actual Stingray
prong that killed Steve
Irwin W KY I think is what you're
supposed to say to that is Cy I sleep in
the satin sheets they strangled Marilyn
Monroe oh [__] uh somebody in the chat
says Chris Chris Farley's Coke
straw me his man cave is a it's just a
perfect Recreation of the [__] Viper
Room [__] [__] tells sorry Al he
tells Alex signin sorry butd I can't
give you a raise this year I'm uh I'm
too busy I'm G to be buying the uh [__]
I forgot oh no Sharon Tate's maternity
clo this is the last bucket of fried
chicken Patrice O'Neil
[Laughter]
ain't can I interest you in Robin
Williams chair
oh [__] slightly used by the way just
FYI only kicked once Chris Ben wa's
Boflex is on display in the center with
a light on it oh no he turned it into a
working
Fountain it was too it was so damn
expensive to put the blex in a glass
cage Bert in the chat says Whitney
Houston's Whitney Houston's
tub there you
go oh [__] oh my God this is some chalk
from the chalk outline in front of the
Viper room um
so uh let's see Natalie Wood swimming
pool there's a lot of was gon to Bu The
Noose that Brody Stevens hung himself
with but then I realized he wasn't
famous
enough Robin Williams suicide note the
fizer bottle that killed Bray Wyatt like
all those kind of things you know what I
mean the fiser bottle the fiser bottle
that killed DMX the FU oh my god oh no
Bray Wyatt it would be the defibrillator
he left in his car yeah that's his fault
honestly that's really his fault uh hey
you want to uh you want to shut up
that'd be cool I think he's talking to
you Frozen
um shut the [__] up Michael Jackson's
profill bottle is another good
one all right we're done come on enough
Amy okay Amy wi house is fridge that's
the last one um s Glen Beck Celebrity
Death museum is the funniest [__]
thing come down to Glen Beck Celebrity
Death Museum Owen Hart's harness oh man
just just blue blazer outfit oh
God God damn it that's so [__] funny
Laura lom's
relevance oh come on [__] Laura lum's
single because she's too busy being
Trump's
girlfriend